the streets outside the Beijing hospital
transformed into a makeshift field
clinic doctors and firefighters racing
to rescue patients from the burning
building some all really desperately ill
in intensive care when the fire took
hold many people wanted to jump out
there was a lot of smoke
many people were screaming nurses were
there medics trying to get everyone out
of there to evacuate they worked very
quickly whilst the firefighters were on
their way panic spread along with the
flames and the dense black smoke
blocking exits below outside patients at
and wheelchairs are on stretchers or
even mattresses on the pavement still
attached to life-saving medical
equipment as doctors decided which were
the most vulnerable and needing to be
transferred first distraught family
members crowded nearby waiting for
information
my mother is inside you have no idea
can imagine the relief knowing that my
father is alive he's 87 years old he was
alone but thank God he's fine
not everyone received good news though
with firefighters searching through the
night to recover the bodies of those who
couldn't get out in time
alexei o'brien al-jazeera